[Musique]
les pétards pour éloigner les mauvais
esprits et une danse des lions au sein
de l'hémicycle du département
ces traditions marque des célébrations
de la nouvelle année du buffle et de
métal tout en respectant les contraintes
sanitaires
la collectivité a tenu à rassembler les
représentants des associations chinoises
pour partager les festivités du nouvel
an soit tout d'abord bonne année car
dire que c'était une très très belle
danse et puis c'est certes c'était un
type différent même temps que la culture
rester dans le coeur si plus important
et voilà trois membres de la communauté
chinoise ont reçu à cette occasion la
médaille départementale du mérite une
récompense pour leur implication dans la
conservation du patrimoine et de la
culture chinoises au sein des temples
grandi à saint denis et à saint pierre
c'est une manière de montrer que dans ce
patrimoine multiculturel multi facettes
de la réunion il ya des il ya des gens
qui comptent
il ya des gens qui ont construit qui ont
donné beaucoup de leur coeur et nous les
remercier c'est aussi on va dire honoré
et cet engagement une grande gratitude
collective
pour le travail dans la continuité de ce
partage des cultures une exposition
nommée comme un roc traitant de
l'immigration chinoise à la réunion est
visible sous le hall du palais de la
source jusqu'au 26 février
[Musique]